[Music]
be brave and close your eyes
distract yourself from the world around
you that will still remain unchanged
when you have the strength to open them
again
[Music]
be brave and close your eyes
be brave and close your eyes
marvel as your thoughts collide within
you as you race to catch up to something
out of your control
[Music]
be brave and close your eyes
let your body lie still while you feel
yourself spiral down a rabbit hole where
you've been before so many times
be brave and close your eyes
feel the adrenaline flow through your
aching lens as you allow yourself to
descend into a reality that is yours and
yours alone
be brave and close your eyes
let yourself be transported to where
your mind needs to be
revel within what the darkness allows
you to see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's so much that we've yet to
understand and even though it feels like
madness this just may be the closest
thing to an alternate reality
as a child i used to believe it so
be brave and close your eyes
where will you go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this is just the story of a girl who
sold her heart
she needed to forget she needed a fresh
start
be careful what you say cause she no
longer feels the same look at her eyes
and see the stains
oh
sorted for a watch to regain the time
she lost
wind is about like seconds since both
your pets crossed sorted for a sweater
keeping out this cold weather body heat
keeps her warm but it won't last forever
likes to think she's clever
sorted for her nickels or your worth
when you're so fickle handed over her
heart felt it heavy and brittle
sorted for a key to regain her dignity
stowed all in a box signed by yours
truly
this is just the story of a girl who
sold her heart
now she's forgotten she's got a fresh
start
be careful what you say cause she no
longer feels the same look at her eyes
and see the stains my love
[Music]
love can't you see
that you can't even breathe
[Music]
was only a day
[Music]
was this now worth the wait
this is just the story of a girl who
sold her heart
now she's forgotten she's got a fresh
[Music]
is it lame i like my own songs no
hello hey everybody
oh geez
i forgot to press pause
that's enough of that
hello who have we got who have we got
hey sidnator
hey makeup match maker march hello
john konsta kant consan
and you said that you love this song so
thank you very much hello baggy
[Music]
hello bastian asensio
hey froggodaco
[Music]
our newest mod in the chat here
welcome welcome
10 out of 10 transition
was she singing was it the song no she
was singing
okay today we are going back to
an wake
uh it's been a couple of weeks so bear
with me i probably have forgotten
all of the controls hey kai how you
doing haven't seen you in here for a
while
uh but yeah we shall play a little bit
more alan wake
uh
[Music]
it's just gonna be yeah it's gonna be me
just figuring out the controls again for
a little bit we finished the first
episode what was it two weeks ago now it
was before halloween
very cool love the idea of the
protagonist being a writer
very cool protagonist i love the idea
that you can pick up sheets of paper and
that will give you hints and clues as to
what is going to happen in the very near
future
that's a very cool addition as well um
so yeah now we'll carry on with episode
two
as usual let me know if the game is too
loud if i am too loud anything like that
hey manuel cr
i don't think i can hear anything right
now
load game please
why is it playing out there
i know
alan wake you are playing out the wrong
technical difficulties
it was playing out the wrong speaker
always professional over on yardman x
actually i spent today um making us new
pop-ups
so you're they're not that great but if
anyone new follows or subscribes today
then you will see them so very exciting
hey ultimate x james
i'm so excited you're doing great thanks
bronco doggo
previously on alan wake
i came to bright falls with my wife
alice thank you for coming here with me
i thought maybe you could write here i
don't want to hear it god damn it alice
oh yeah
he's going through a major creative
burnout
i woke up behind the wheel of a crashed
car i'm missing a week i was attacked by
shadowy men straight from a nightmare
the sheriff took me to the lake alice
and i had stayed at
but the cabin had disappeared
yeah a lot of stuff happened we were
forced to write oh three years ago
[Music]
honey i'm home
back here sweetie how was it worst
weather i've ever seen yep he does not
look happy
it'll warm you up
okay
oh my gosh can you see that
can you see this rain
that is crazy our sensitivity i remember
saying the thing last time we played
this game whoa jesus
look at that rain in that wind
coffee's on
great thanks i'll need it if i'm gonna
finish this by tomorrow
what is she doing
i mean i don't i don't blame him for
being in a bad mood
with that
wind and rain although it looks like
he's gone very nice apartment
so this dude used to be like a world
renowned renowned writer
uh did very well and now
he has got a major burnout i can't
remember for how long but it's been a
matter of like years some crazy years
so this was three years ago
so hey are you just interested
they're on your desk tell me what you
think no kidding
i didn't think you'd get them done this
quickly on occasion i can perform all
sorts of miracles my dear
oh really
well you seem to think so last night
oh
oh
from what they alluded to
pg here keep it pg
hey lydia
so maybe this is right after his last
book or something because she's doing
the mock-ups for it
no no cannot open my own door
wow look at that sunflower how did it
grow this tall
with such little light like it's not
getting any light from here because i
mean all we have across from us is
another gigantic building
that's not that's not possible
trust me i know i i'm dealing with
plants right now one of them's not doing
very well i'm trying all i can to save
save it
these look really good
oh sure until barry gets his hands on
them which by the way will happen over
my dead body
the last time hey death 157.
oh and speaking of barry he called
oh
oh yeah [ __ ] she wait let's check the
fuse box i want to get the manuscript
i'm right here i'm on it honey please
hurry okay okay okay fine uh f5 i'm just
gonna read the manuscript because why
not
and the sudden stop at the end
i'd lane here in the snow while the
lurid chain of scenes that had led me
here kept playing in my head
a rerun of my own private snuff movie a
memory of my corpse
alone at my own wake
thinking in metaphors again
the femme fatale was gone
only a sour taste remained of the kiss
damn
uh there's another page um how did we
open that again
this was a late goodbye
thirteen years after i'd gotten my
revenge
it had finally caught up with me
it had been a long time to bear the pain
my blood painted the snow red
a gruesome slushie
dissolved all the scattered painkillers
and
leisurely dripped down to the sewer
mingling with the bile of the city
becoming one with it
i can see them now
my wife and my baby
honey i'm home
okay
so this is a manuscript for a new book
anyway we need to be going because our
wife so if you don't know our wife is
deathly terrified
yeah i know
she's really scared of the dark um so
where the fricking fricking frick frick
would a generator be
i really need those lights i know you do
but i'm right here baby i'm fine i'm
fine
get the lights back on now please
honey it's a power outage i've got the
flashlight okay
you okay you okay
i'm sorry
i just
it just really spooked me
don't worry we'll just break out the
candles
i know it's stupid but it's just
especially when i'm not prepared for it
you know it gets to me
i love you
tell me a story writer
okay
i used to have these nightmares when i
was a kid the dark really spooked me too
when it got really bad my mom gave me
this old light switch she called it the
clicker the clicker huh yeah if i ever
got scared of the dark i could just flip
the switch and a magic light would scare
the monsters away oh sure
here it is alan maybe it'll help you too
yeah nice story ryder boy you made that
up right now didn't you no no
seriously
i love you
even if you are a liar
thanks for this
[Music]
[Music]
hello clay
okay back in the present day
how do you feel mr wick any nausea
disorientation anything like that
mr wake
how are you feeling
i'm okay my head's fine i had to lie
about my headache and memory loss he'd
send me to a hospital why is everything
so just leave without her
very well um i don't think you have a
concussion but you've obviously been
through quite a shock you should take it
easy why is nobody asking him where his
wife is
well then mr wake we're done here
where pain gets any worse or you
experience any other symptoms i guess
they just don't see me mine i'll let you
get on with it then was he fishing a
sheriff breakers waiting for you she's
very good at her job i'm sure she can
locate you okay they already know she's
missing doc nelson was the image of a
small town doctor sheriff breaker had
called him to the station to take a look
at the cut in my head okay
so yeah they found us in the woods and
we were like shooting all these shadow
people um
but the police found us and we couldn't
exactly tell them what was going on
oh she's a beauty ain't she not the
biggest i ever caught if you can believe
that coming from an old fisherman like
me but she's right up there now she's in
a large mouth bass which is what you're
after if you prefer a lure now if you
want either trout or salmon oh gosh i
did not need your life story sir
okay you a fishing man no
it doesn't really matter i suppose but
it can be very relaxing out there
you can't get me off the water this time
of year
closest thing to heaven i'll take your
word for it doc
that man loves fishing
okay i think that's about all we can see
so let's go and talk to
sarah
are you okay you look so it's that lady
who's scared of the lies
everything seems to be fine
i don't have the luxury of being
complacent deputy grant the bulbs will
need changing soon you can't change them
in the dark i'll be sure to take care of
it miss weaver have a nice day now
very good
i'll come back later on to remind you
just in case oh my gosh
it's that creepy woman that watched us
down the dark hallway
oh okay that was cynthia weaver i guess
you can call her the town eccentric she
used to be the editor of the local
newspaper but she's focused on
other things these days
where i come from
as you can see she's a little obsessed
with maintaining the light bulbs of the
whole town refuses to step on shadows
things like that back in her day she
wrote about all sorts of weird things in
the paper bright falls has a colorful
history of course what small town hasn't
i mean from what we experienced last
night i'd say
she has a reason to be scared oh cells
where's
her office not in here is it oh examine
yeah it's a mulligan here i'm at
stuckey's gas station with thornton
there's no sign of him or wait wait wait
wait yeah this is thornton look we've
located the brave float it's here that's
some goodness right stuck it was
supposed to be driving it at the
rehearsals today over oh give me that
mulligan here looks like someone really
thrashed the garage over okay roger that
guys keep looking for stuckey jane's out
stookie
hey
kaiser
um okay let's read this other manuscript
alice sees this
through the viewfinder lining up the
shot cauldron lake was breathtaking
something caught her eye a figure
standing in the shadows behind the cabin
like a thin woman in a black dress
she lowered the camera and looked again
no one there just a collection of bushes
that looked vaguely human-shaped
she shook her head and laughed they're
freaky
the sheriff wants to see you in her
office mr wake
yeah yeah hey eb what's alan up to now
he is about to see the sheriff and he's
gonna lie and say that he
is fine and didn't see anything because
he doesn't want everyone to think that
he's crazy
identifying features he has a knack for
winning contests
yes
identifying feature
sure
come in mr wake your phone's on the desk
the battery was dead it's charged now oh
thank you very much
have you started looking for my wife yet
my men are already on it now can you
tell me what happened i'm not sure i
can't remember we were arguing i walked
out of the cabin the cabin on cauldron
lake
how did you end up at stuckey's gas
station i wanted to tell her what had
happened last night but i couldn't she'd
lock me up
excuse me i need to take this
hello
alan please help me
alice
stop talking to the law you'll do
exactly what i say if you ever want to
see your wife again
who is this
there's a hole in the fence on the left
look inside the junker
i left a little something there to
convince you we're all on the same page
here
after you ditch the cops you're gonna
meet me in elderwood national park
there's a spot called lovers peak
midnight
don't do nothing stupid pal
for watching you
okay
mr wake can i help you with anything i
need to get some air the sheriff said i
could go out back i couldn't go anywhere
yet i had to play along with the caller
alice's life was at stake
he's one of our regulars
hey can you turn the light boy it's on
the deputies they won't they don't
understand
they won't listen to me i i need it to
be bright in here
they go
thank you hey
you're all right
you're a good guy
don't let anybody tell you different
you know i shouldn't even be in here
the cops they got it
all wrong see
sure sure i beat him up but i wasn't
drunk
i mean i wasn't drunk at the time i only
got drunk
yeah it sounds like you should be in
here
unless you gotta listen carefully now
oh you think they're species
sure well we've seen things as well
though to be fair hey attica you're
doing great first time watching thank
you so much for watching
glad i'm glad you think so
let's read this mask to describe the
dark presence as intelligent would have
implied human qualities on something
decidedly inhuman
nonetheless it found the one spot in the
diner that was dark enough
some light spilled into the corridor
ravaging it but it took the pain
horrible as it was the writer would soon
fix that he would be coming to the one
place where it still had power oh no
that's probably where we're on our way
to now the early morning light hurt my
eyes and made my headache the man on the
phone had said go through the fence on
the left oh
he wants to give us an old pickup truck
yes
where's the um
hole
look at the way he jumps
uh kick
so strong
alice's driver's license had been placed
on the front seat the caller meant
business
oh how how did you do that i didn't even
look
barry
thank god where the hell have you been
i've been trying to reach you for a week
you and alice i've been worried sick i
flew out yesterday i'm here here in
bright falls
oh listen
i'm in the sheriff's
come and get me i can't talk now
what the hell is going on i had to get
the sheriff to let me go
i needed to get to elderwood national
park to meet alice's kidnappers
can we pull this and then come up there
no
i think that him and the weird light
bulb lady have seen them they seem
really crazy about having the lights on
oh yeah definitely frogo doggo like the
first time we saw that lady she didn't
want to go down a really spooky dark
like hallway to a toilet and that's
actually where we got the keys to our
house that actually doesn't exist
because we
uh we lost our wife we went to look for
her we ended up in some woods and
killing some random shadow people and
then the police found us and then took
us to where we said we stayed and it
nothing was there
so
weird stuff weird stuff be happening
also we just picked up another piece of
paper
was it this the kidnapper fired his gun
one last time and the shadow vanished
into the darkness it had come from
see nothing too awake
the thought of alice in his hands was
revolting we stood on the wooden
platform of love or speak the waterfall
in the mountain behind us the lights of
the radio mass blinking red in the
heights above
i fought with the urge to take a swing
force myself to speak
let's cut the act now
where's my wife oh we are gonna have
this scene see this is what i like about
this game you get to read scenes before
they happen and this is probably gonna
happen in the future so the kidnapper
fired his gun one last time the shadow
vanished into the darkness it had come
from so the kidnapper is also killing
the shadows
um
i don't know why
uh sitting in front of the wooden
platform will love his peak waterfall
the mountain behind us
i thought with the urge to take us away
yeah okay yeah that'll happen
oh coffee
hey emma hola
let's turn you on folks it's been
another long night and uh it's about
time for me to sign off
god knows i need my beauty sleep
just one more item before i go
it's been a busy night for the sheriff's
department we've had a few broken
windows
even a reported shots fired on main
street deputies mulligan and thornton
had to deal with two intoxicated young
men who were celebrating the completion
of their deer fest float now folks we
get this every year i know it's exciting
the big day is almost here but
let's save it for the party and leave
the gun play for the shooting
competition
no point in getting all worked up yet
don't shoot guns cause guns are just bad
yeah i'm a lyricist
ah can i go in here
oh i can
oh this is where i came from
so how am i gonna exit then
oh whoa writer is a light that reveals
the world of his story from darkness
shapes it from nothingness the way a
sculptor carves a statue from a block of
granite if i stop
the world i'm making dies
darkness will reclaim it oh it's like
the neverending story into the dark
alice's life is at stake but i can't
think about that or i'll lose it the
dread lingers at the edge of perception
i'll push on anything is possible here
i'll write the story i'll save her
yes you will alan
i believe in you see are you here are
you on that keyboard you're probably on
the keyboard aren't you and we're just
playing your story i just wanted to
settle all the damage
oh he's here already that was fast
certainly caused on their reason
are you feeling any better mr wake i'd
like to leave am i free to go well we
still need to talk about under arrest
no of course not but i need to know
where you'll be staying so i can get in
touch with you i'd avoid the motel the
majestic is known for its roaches the
cabins at elderwood are pretty nice
though that sounds perfect i'm dr emile
hartman i'd like to invite you to stay
at cauldron lake lodge did you talk to
my wife i had the pleasure of discussing
your situation with her on several
occasions did you set something up with
her i invited her here my clinic is a
place where
i don't know why
that freaked me
i did not see that hit coming off of my
client who are you oh thank you so much
for the super chat i really appreciate
that mr wake you talk to me you yokels
won't know what hit you once i sick my
lawyers on your asses no harm done so
coming i don't know
i don't want to press charges
mr wake
my offer still stands my alert is in the
wrong place get me out of here
sorry
all right back to the game
thank you for good no good hell was that
about al
we don't need a replay of that thing
with the paparazzi i thought they were
gonna lock you up
what thing with the paparazzi
did he get all angry with the paparazzi
i told barry everything he thought i was
certifiable but when he heard about the
manuscript i had him the fact that i'd
written something even if i couldn't
remember it was enough for him he
smelled money and he believed that alice
had been kidnapped anything beyond that
was another story i had a midnight
appointment with the kidnapper in a
place called lover's peak somewhere in
elderwood national park the plan was to
rent a cabin i don't like it al i don't
like any of it it's not good in fact
it's the absolute opposite of good
mr wake
barry you've found him i rose oh wow i
was just thinking about him
i was just bringing rusty some coffee
he's on the balcony looking after max
poor thing i really need to go great to
see you again mr wake later
no sir stop who's max
what an airhead
what a camera takes a swing at everybody
this is not her oh cool she's a very
nice girl and more importantly a fan you
like even as a fan site dedicated to you
and she was very helpful when i was
looking for you seriously al what you
were saying in the car
just listen to yourself what you shot a
guy and his body just disappeared what
was the last time you slept are you high
have you been drinking
no just a lot of coffee a week and
someone's got alice and everything stand
what it sounds like when you say stuff
like that don't get me wrong it's a good
story could be a bestseller but when you
start confusing fiction with reality
you're buying yourself a ticket to the
funny farm wait here
it likes this jacket
yeah the camera is super sensitive
i've had to put the mouth sensitivity
like way down for it
dead pretty is this game has pretty
little autumn colors
big
stiffer spicy balls is it does it say
that no spicy barbecue
big stuffer
spicy barbecue and there's yummies
this is
let me just have a little look around
here first
back to charlie
the skeleton of a colombian mammoth
mammoth colombia
this specimen special run this specimen
estimated to be 14 000 years old was
recovered from the labrae tar pits in
1981. it was donated to the elder wood
national park in 1998
when the colombian manoff became
washington state fossil
washington state fossil named bucktooth
charlie it has since become the park's
official mass guard
oh these are cute
what
oh hello hello
see that's actually quite pretty isn't
it
easy there boy i'm almost done hey rusty
right you rent cabins oh mr wake i'd
shake your hand but mine are kind of
full here
actually i'm sorry about this would you
mind grabbing the registration form from
the desk it's just across from bucktooth
charlie okay sure
crazy poachers
max here got his foot caught in a trap
they're illegal to use here hell you're
not supposed to hunt within the park at
all but that doesn't stop some lowlifes
hell at least max is going to be okay
you got lucky
no
max is still groggy from the shot i gave
him and i'd rather not leave him alone
just yet the forms on the desk across
from the mammoth skeletons
you can't just go and meet a kidnapper
those situations always end up in
disaster you gotta talk to the cops
they won't believe me just like you
she's my wife and it's my call can we
talk about this later no
this whole thing
listen you hit your head i mean jeez ow
come on you got to understand how crazy
all this sounds if you're trying to pull
a joke on me freak me out it's working
ha ha let's have a laugh on barry well
you had me going there real funny al you
can quit it now
[Music]
hey kyle hey rexella
can we get a thermos check um
how would i do this
uh
what would it be in
how do i do that
like yes if i can figure out how
is it in like
manuscript no
bag
what would it be in
statistics oh
ah
maybe
coffee thermos is found
13 out of 100
unlucky 13.
i think that's what you wanted to see
wasn't it
if someone did that to my dog yeah i'd
be very upset as well
okay i did the thing
i think this is the form you wanted
and here are the keys
okay you're all set mr waken glad to
have you staying here not that i have a
dog tell me how to get something
oh sure it's at the end of the nature
trail just follow the paths you'll get
to it eventually it's an easy walk nice
spot too
okay thank you for my keys if you have
any trouble finding it just keep your
eyes on the radio mast it's right below
that oh and hey if you take a walk in
the woods watch your step so you don't
end up like max
i guess i'm a little worried we got a
bunch of campers out there we haven't
heard from it's not like these people
are on a schedule but with the traps
well you know i just don't want any
trouble yeah
thanks
i can see that
i don't really think about traps when i
go you're asking me to believe that you
shot a dude who went
into thin air a guy who was bulletproof
until you pointed a flashlight at him
you hear that from people who end up
spending time in padded rooms strapped
to their beds wearing white shirts with
two long tangled up sleeves and eating a
healthy diet of pills
al you make cruel jokes about people who
believe that kind of stuff you're the
skeptic you gave me an hour-long lecture
on homeopathy last month what was it if
there's no proof it's pure [ __ ]
period
guess the laughs on me then ow come on
i mean
okay
okay maybe something weird happened to
you okay
well thanks for the heartfelt vote of
confidence all i'm saying is you gotta
throw me a bone here bestseller what
would you think if it was me
there's no way you should be going out
at midnight with a gun
no one asked you to come here barry
either work with me on this or go
straight back to new york your choice
what's he gonna do
i understand his concerns though it does
sound like quite a crazy plan
how
al
we should go to the sheriff or call the
fbi damn it barry the killer
this is not a goddamn debate i would
have expected that land to make more
noise
he said to come alone okay okay then i
understand
you're my best friend and i'm worried
that you're not right in the head
tell me what to do to help and i'll do
it you stay here and if i'm not back by
morning call the cavalry
are you okay be careful with the natives
owl angie's locals are dangerous
everybody hates a tourist or it'll be
deliverance all over again the lamb
picked itself back up bless you how did
it do this oh this place is trying to
kill me
i bet there's mold in here spores poison
ivy god knows what this is so not worth
a 15 commission
the lamp picked itself back up did you
not see this
spooky i don't know where you can shove
that flashlight wherever you point that
thing out
hello
okay
i'm still not 100 with this
mouth sensitivity
so
so sensitive okay
coffee
such big coffee flasks
batteries thank you very much
anything over here
on the sofa
no
oh sorry chair
real funny al real funny
thank you
sit here in the dark till you come back
or until i get eaten by a groove
there you go put them back on for yours
just joking
love you
which way do we go out
okay that way
it did trigger some spooky music
hello chris i'll wait here out i'll hold
down the fort i'll be with your spirit
every step of the way al
yeah
now
i don't really blame him
to be honest
this is crazy what we're doing
barry had never gotten along with alice
but he knew allen loved her with an
almost frightening intensity and now
something had happened to alice and here
was al armed with a gun and saying
things people got put in batted sales
for
it was as if his friend had experienced
a massive psychotic episode and was now
totally disconnected from reality it
scared the [ __ ] out of barry
this is what i said i understand
yes
it sounds
bunkers
but also
i don't know what would you do in that
situation because you don't want your
friend to to go into a really dangerous
situation on their own but then also
you don't want to put yourself in a
dangerous situation either and i should
have gone to the cops
this wasn't the smartest thing i'd ever
done but i was still angry with barry
for trying to talk me out of it these
people had called me right in the
sheriff's station the cops wouldn't
scare them and they had alice
barry had the keys to the car he rented
wasn't a long walk to the visitor center
and it wouldn't be any use to me in the
forest
what the frick those crows sound like
okay
so i need to
gosh
i guess i'm just gonna jump into the
thick of it because i've forgotten how
to change battery and i'm guessing r is
to reload my bullets at least
jesus
oh
where did that bird go
spooky
anyone in here
oh spooky tire swing
welcome back to the show folks as
promised our very own dr nelson has just
parked his rear end in the studio doc
what's your deerfest plan like
my plan you'll make it sound a lot more
organized than i ever said
no plan really just taking the
atmosphere i'm getting a little too
rickety to do much more than that you
know oh tell me about it no sack race
for us older gentlemen huh
that's exactly fact but i'm gonna check
out the oh [ __ ] and i'll be one of the
bargains that was creepy as [ __ ]
well that takes a different kind of gust
did you see that did everyone see that
oh yeah it's my kind of exercise without
dying seriously i did not expect that i
thought it was really safe in here i
mean i think i am
i didn't expect to see anything out the
window that was so good just caught a
heck of a large mouth bass early this
morning
but you're not taking part in the
fishing contest
no no not this year see pat i'm just not
that competitive anymore no i just like
to take it everyone's like yeah yes we
saw that yes
a spook a spook indeed
considering your track record we're just
gonna listen to this radio and then
we're going to go out there
and i'll probably die
well that that's kind of you to say
oh yeah of course just music i was like
where does that eerie sound uh
i'm actually gonna go options
controls let's have a look at all this
oh gosh
uh
okay
key bindings
right so
to do
uh
okay boost flash all right reload
battery is q
focus is f yeah i know that
select pistol and then r must be to
reload the gun even though it's not
saying that
oh there reload okay sweet right q and e
that's all i need to know
let's let's go
i'm just stalling time here ready aren't
i boom
hello i saw you out here
i really didn't expect to see anything
out the window it was such a good jump
scare
oh what a nice place to sit and just
watch the world go by
oh jesus what the [ __ ]
why is everything
i don't understand
okay why did i
oh i thought that was like was a massive
shadow of a massive person then off this
game geez
lover's peak
moonshine cave
anyone gonna be in here
ah this is not
like it'll have a working light switch
no no no
no working light switch is very sad
it does have a tv though which
works even though there's no
crime and punishment
the cancer and cure of civilization
but some crimes are impossible to punish
especially
in night springs
[Music]
tonight's episode
do you want to watch the whole episode
we watched last time
he's inside agent he's a weird one
so you're confessing to killing that guy
huh why
yeah but why would you do that i mean i
would love to work in a game like this
and just make stupid videos to fit in
the game i'd have so much fun
assault the victim's head area
repeatedly with the weapon of choice
being a pair of bare fists
wow that sentence really flows there's
so many feathers in here
maybe you're not the literary type okay
so you mess him up but why
who was that guy
we couldn't idea
why would a guy like you do him like
that
i didn't like his face well you must
have hated it because you really went to
town there i mean there's no way to tell
what he looked like no id on him either
that must be difficult
but then we ran the fingerprints got a
match
your prince identical
huh how about that
his face
how about that the white shirt is on the
dead guy
it's plenty red now
i won't get away with this
do you really think that's
irrelevant to me
i had plenty of time to talk to my boy
before the cops arrived you know
he won't stop screaming am i right
you think he's ever gonna be okay
i left my mark
believe me you you bastard what you
gonna shoot me
what's the point i'm going to prison
you got me
don't understand any of this
[Music]
you'll become like him
[Music]
that's it
night springs
well that was fun
glad we watched that
what the [ __ ] is that noise
oh cross
are they evil crows
they're gonna get me
and if i don't get them first
okay
okay
ring ring hello
that's a hiking trail that's an obvious
trail that's an open car boot
pointing out to the obvious here but you
know just in case anybody is watching
and not listening no the other way
around listening and not watching i will
tell them everything
do not feed the wildlife
again a bunch of manuscripts here
you know i quite enjoy the pacing of
this game i know i know
it's like a little bit slower
than especially
newer games of like horror and stuff but
well apart from
i guess like amnesia rebreaths had its
slow moments as well but then when it
gets
when the shadow people come they come
and i die
where is he
[Music]
oh no
mr wake
oh hell
it happened just the way it was oh good
the dog's okay dog's okay
that's good true
it knew
so dark
it'll come back for me
you must
the lights
in the office
i have the key
okay rusty
hang on i'll be right back
whatever did this couldn't be far
rusty had found a page from the
manuscript it would help me understand
what had happened oh hello baby
good boy oh it's okay
you're you're a brave boy uh one second
sir i need to read my manuscripts that i
picked up
um
oh here we go rusty dying visitor center
was heavy with an awful smell as if some
rotten drown thing had crawled up from
its grave
rusty kept coughing blood my eyes were
drawn to the twisted shape of his broken
leg the attack had been vicious
max wind in his cage rusty's eyes were
wild with fear and terror he gasped mr
wake it happened just the way it was on
that page
there you go
so he's gonna die like this no
oh no
thank you gaming with malachi and
welcome
it will come up in a second just just
wait for it the lights have already
there there it is thank you
rose knew that rusty was in love with
her and she liked him too she liked him
a lot he taught her to dance and life
had certainly taught her the value of a
man who was gentle
he treated her well made her smile made
her feel good but rusty wasn't the
prince of her dreams and that tended to
underline the unbearable truth she was
no closer to that hollywood magic than
he was
hmm
but rusty wasn't the prince of her
dreams okay so
well like
he didn't get the girl that he wanted
but i don't get that how that would
correlate to him being dead here
what
does not make any sense
it's not making no sense sir um this
door no this stuff
what
what other doors could there be
which door dude
oh here
sorry sorry i know you're dying i'm just
uh i'm losing
losing the weight
like the forest at night
woke up
is he dying
no
okay i'm leaving
i know it will okay it hasn't finished
with me yet oh gosh
okay we'll go over there i'll turn the
lights on i'll get the lights back on
for you the only way to make sure that
rusty was safe was to get the power
running and the lights back on
be careful i will
hey torti amir have you tried devour no
i have not
ah okay where could
there's another manuscript there
is it gonna give us some insight
into something
at the last instant i changed direction
and threw myself down
the axe splintered the trunk of a tree
i stumbled into the pool of bright light
my lungs burned i was too exhausted to
move
i tense as i waited for the killing blow
but it never came
i raised my head
nothing moved in the darkness beyond for
the moment bathed in the cold light i
was safe
okay maybe that's how i'll get out of
this then
god it sounds intense
i don't want it
um
oh loli what do we have on here then
thank you very much very nice very nice
uh is that everything
okay let's go to the back
someone had destroyed the circuit
breaker there was no way to get the
lights back on
no rusty
[Music]
rusty
[Music]
the ground was covered with oily patches
that looked like liquid darkness
oh
oh cute cute for the battery
where is my shotgun
oh my guns are gone this is real sad
can i stay by the electric electric pole
because technically that is light
oh how's the dog
sized hole in the wall
it was the dog escaping
i hope so that's what i wish it would be
but i know it probably isn't going to do
that don't feed the animals
what
fishing
no it's one of these big ones again
oh gosh jesus christ
this is this is why it's high
sensitivity right for these guys
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
how many shots does it take to kill a
rusty spoon
oh [ __ ] a duck
uh oh hello hello yes please look at all
this yummy yummy yum
oh [ __ ]
yes
queen
queen allen
ah okay good good good very good
okay
anything behind this rock no
oh it she knows
this way
where's the dog i hope the dog was okay
don't turn around
don't close your eyes
um
oh okay
oh here it's like a healer point
good nice thank you
hello hello
mr wake here
what the hell was that i saw it from the
window i thought i saw something
forget about it barry it's just me going
crazy oh geez
oh geez
you're not crazy i wish you were crazy
but you're not crazy
now be careful
stay in the cabin don't not crazy i
tried to tell you
hello eternal cheesecake what a name
very nice name
anything over this way it seemed like
the trees were leading me towards that
way but i i don't think so cause i'm
here now there's nothing there
okay so now
he finally believes us but you know
too late in it
too late sucker we're already gone he's
gonna have to phone for himself now
what's down here
a hiking trail
[Music]
okay i think we have to go down that way
do we or did we go this way
no no we definitely go down that way
almost miss this though
oh wow look at him girl just climbing
over tables
uh okay
let's give it a little read
in that last instant of consciousness
rusty thought about rose he was older
than she was rose was barely out of her
teens but she made him feel young and
forget what a train wreck is long dead
marriage
he still wore the ring okay he'd been
waiting for her to tell him to take it
off
now she never would
oh okay so i guess that was why
it wasn't all that good
i mean i guess it still wasn't bad it
was just
unless he was still married and she was
his bit on the side then that would be
bad
for your safety stay on designated
hiking trail nope
oh yeah wait
there's like traps out here aren't there
yeah maybe i should then
lover's peak was at the far end of the
nature trail
okay
oh is there a cave down here
[Music]
the cave oh i don't know where to go
which way should we go should go down to
the cave
over there
okay this place is creepy
slightly frequent boot like a activity
this is good though
this means we find good things
shot come on
yeah baby
got me
[Music]
indeed
um now i actually want to
i'm sorry
um
i want to put the
verticality back up a little bit
just a tiny bit just the tiniest bit
i don't think i'm ever going to be
a perfect
sensitivity
but i am aware how fast those speedy
boys go
and speedy speedy girls
speedy everything's
do you reckon no
i'm sure we won't have to
kill the dog
i was like will the dog come back or
something we'd have to fight because if
so i really don't want to but i don't
think so i think it's just humans
do you not feed the
wildlife oh
psych
this is no
oh god oh god
what
why did you do that to me again
oh for [ __ ] sake
[ __ ] sake
die
anywhere in the toilet hello
can i use this phone oh
no
we got batteries
oh my gosh alan please put on that
they came from up here can i look up
here but i'm very aware that there might
be traps
it doesn't like there's anything up here
okay
oh let you catch your breath for a
minute old man
okay so that's the next safe spot back
there
we can make that all right oh no it's up
there okay
we've reached a checkpoint that's a good
sign
uh what's up this weather
is that way to love his peak
what's it this way
ah i don't like the lack of light
thank you very much for the manuscript
okay let's read this
nobody in brightfall seemed to know
where al was but rose the waitress at
the diner had seen him oh yeah from what
barry could tell al pretty much fell off
the face of the earth when he left the
diner
rose was just the kind of fan that al
hated but she really tried to help she
was smart too knew a lot about what was
going on in the town knew a lot about al
even knew who barry was
barry liked her that was no big surprise
when it came to winning we all knew that
barely saw eye to eye
was
um
even knew
it's weird that she is like such a
psycho fan like she knows everything
about his life
i guess maybe not psycho just
you know she had a lot of time spent
to do a lot of digging hey
whoa
i didn't know allen could do circus
tricks did you see that
that was cool
um
better watch out for the traps
there will be traps and then woods
oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ]
back to the light back to the light back
to the light back to why i don't like
this it's really scary spooky scary
spooky
i am a [ __ ]
oh
no
i'll go up this
way i follow the trail
it's not helping
honey i just need to get out there
please don't be a psych
oh
beautiful
i already got one
but i'll take another one
oh nice bear
this is where people go to meditate um
let's meditate with the bears
um
okay
oh why is your vision going so weird
dude
wearing a visor he's wearing a visor
he'd be wearing it either
oh [ __ ] jesus fight
oh my gosh
okay nice let's let's go back up and
regain our health
[Music]
and back down again
ah switch out for the shotgun because
why not
okay so we killed some fellas here the
great old one
oh wait what i can read something
the great old one
sorry i just elbowed the mic
failed by lightning in 1937 this
exceptionally tall rocky mountain
douglas fair
was over 200 years old according to
local legends it stretched beyond the
stars after it fell it was measured to
be 66 meters tall nearly a record length
beyond the stars they say
impossible
uh i could explore more
but you know what i'm not going to
oh jesus
die
die
taste my
lights
i need a double barrel shotty
i'm not good
if it's not double barrel okay
uh do i just carry on and hope for the
best or do i run back toward the light
let's [ __ ] just carry on and hope for
the best
probably not the best
idea
but look my health is slowly regaining
oh jesus no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no i refuse to play
[ __ ] jesus christ alan please
sir will you just get better at running
no [ __ ] off you know [ __ ] back
oh it is double barrel
oh my message is reloaded one shot
noise
yeah yeah yeah
yeah amazing
we're all good
we're in there like
okay we need to change our gap
bye shotty you did brilliant
so glad to know you
what's in here
i'll take that i'll take that
yep
definitely can't use that phone
oh
here we go
i turned the corner afraid of what the
flashlight's beam might reveal
suddenly a roughly painted symbol of a
torch glowed in the light behind it
hidden by a rock sat a battered metal
trunk
it was here for a reason pack with
supplies this is batteries us in the
cave thing
things you need to make it through the
darts
though
something left behind by someone who
knew what i knew and more
okay it would be nice to get some flares
that's good flares like obliterate
everything in the vicinity so
yeah it would be very nice to get some
flares
hello eli what's this
the taken are filled with darkness
darkness
oh yeah i figured that i mean you only
come out at night
is that a bloody t-shirt
oh gosh
oh gosh
did you see that movement back there me
no likey i want flour please
blah
[ __ ] hell
okay here we go
i can't tell if i'm helping being up
here if i'm just backing myself into a
[ __ ] corner
[Applause]
i'm really bad at dodging in this game
because you gotta press shift and like
left and right i think
i can't tell like oh there needs to be
better indication of who has already
been like killed by the light and who
hasn't do you know what i mean because
you have to like do the light first and
then shoot them there needs to be a
better indication
of who you need to like
whittle down via using the light
and who
is still okay oh this is gonna be tough
there's so many of them and i don't have
any shots gun ammo or anything
yes i see you you're very spooky very
creepy
oh [ __ ] off there's so many
you know what screw you off
ah jesus
oh
no there's too many of them i can't do
this
i need to practice
dodging it's like shift and then
left to right
at the same time i don't know or maybe i
can just do it while i'm holding shift
i mean
i don't want to do this
oh
left or right or something
i can't dodge literally forgotten how to
dodge
can't be those buttons
thing is i always have my
finger on shift because i'm always
trying to run
it feels weird to take it off and then
try and
spam it while going left and right just
to dodge
please don't come to my side i can't
[ __ ] see there's a tree in my way i
hate you i hate you all i don't know how
to dodge i [ __ ] hate you [ __ ] get off
my [ __ ] life get out of my life get
out of my life there's too many of you
run
oh my god
oh my god no no i don't know what to go
to there's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's too many
i don't know how to do this there's too
many there's so
many
oh my god
back just run
just run i don't know how
this seems impossible mate like
am i missing something here
oh my god
am i actually missing something here
i feel like i need your backwards i feel
like i've missed something that would
really help me like blairs
[Music]
maybe i should look around for a bit
more
because that seems way too
difficult right let me have a little
look
i love these flares
just got to keep an eye out for um
traps
flares flares flares of the flares flare
for flipping flares
because no longer scared when you got
the flares
definitely nothing around here
are you down here
no ah what if i haven't missed anything
and i'm just expected to do it with my
pistol
that would be sad
you definitely have to chase them
because i tried to go past them
and one guy just came in front of me and
then they all came behind me and
obliterated me and also this dude alan
wake does not run very long
he gets tired very quickly
and then he does like a little
this
a little uh very slow jog
which is not good against
super quick enemies
at least no one's getting this now
just gotta find a flare and then
we'll be okay
where could there be a flare
if you were a flare where would you be
maybe in here
[Music]
hmm
what
i'm surprised he can even
move a lot but just can't run very fast
no
i feel like i've honestly explored most
places
maybe down here
oh jeez
there's a lot of sounds in alan wake
that kind of sound like someone's
screaming see
the only place is in there and i've
already been in this the cave
and then there's back up there
oh no
i don't think there are any
i think i used all the shotties up when
i shouldn't have
thanks for following
rain moonstone
i don't know why all of my pop-ups have
changed colors it's supposed to be
something else but ah i'll look at it
some other time
reed
read this this cave was the site of
frequent and lucrative bootlegger
activity throughout the prohibit
prohibit
prohibition it was mostly used for
temporary storage of alcohol but at
times alcohol was also distilled on the
purposes
okay cool
but where are these flares
did i miss something
i've come all the way back here and
literally
nothing
there's no furs in here is there
oh my gosh
okay this is tough
hmm
okay
time to go then
come on alan wake
well we're just going to try loads of
tactics
to see if
we can get past this next
bit because damn it's hard
maybe i can run through it a different
way but
i don't know there's so many people
it seems like i really should have at
least one flag on with me
come on little hour wakey
catch your breath
oh gosh
i don't like dying
i should have played on easy
okay so let me scope out the area where
can i go i'm where can i not go so i
can't go there
oh [ __ ] off you little [ __ ] bag oh maybe
oh [ __ ] off you don't [ __ ]
sorry i took a bit too far i'm just
getting so annoyed i just want to have a
look but okay so let's try and fight
them and have a look
maybe i can just go straight you've got
this thanks malakai
i'm gonna cry
let's have a breakdown over this
okay
go ally wakey
[ __ ] where did they come from they let
you just come right behind you i hate
them i hate them i hate them i hate them
i hate them there's nothing here this is
a dead end i thought that something was
going to be here that would be very
helpful or some [ __ ] but it wasn't
it wasn't
it wasn't helpful
and now i'm just trapped in a freaking
corner i hate this
thank you so much for your donation
oh geez
i don't i literally don't know if i can
do this i feel like this is the end of
allen wake because i can't do this
oh
[ __ ] off you look [ __ ] back [ __ ] off
what's behind me oh
right let's go up here
but
it's a tree it's a tree it's a train
there's so much [ __ ] going on mate
oh god
i can't do this
i'm really scared that i'm gonna have to
just never play this game again no i
don't want to get past there
it's just i keep like just running into
trees and crap and [ __ ] everywhere
thank you so much from my daughter hey i
really appreciate the support i don't
think i've found anything this hard
in a freaking long long time
okay this is working a bit better
okay yes shoot the big dude shoot the
big dude
oh this is working much better than me
okay yeah oh my god
i think i got the big dude i got toe
crabs
come on
yes
oh my god
okay
i just have to move backwards and not
into the fight i go away from the fight
i don't make sense now
okay
thank you so much to
to everyone who believed in me and gave
me nice encouraging words i really
appreciate it
ah
jeez and thanks for gaming uh gaming
with malachi and froggo doggo for
just super chat
oh jeez
i understand that i'm getting crap
you know when you're just like playing a
game or you get running into something
and then your toes just start to go like
this and then you get toe grab i don't
know maybe it's just me i'm sure that
happens with you
but yeah that's what just happened
we did it
we did it
ah
jeez and we didn't even need a flat
doggo yeah can we save the dogger i have
a gun
okay let's make sure we pick up
everything in this area
because we are now in
major need of any kind of
uh
ammunition would be great please and
thank you
you know what i hate i hate how like
relatively easy that last attempt was oh
and
my other attempts were absolutely
abysmal
hey we tried a new strategy so sometimes
it works sometimes it doesn't
seems like there should be something
around here but i think i'm just
climbing up
places where i shouldn't be
what you need to do to try and find uh
like loot stacks
is look for hidden messages through
that will be revealed to you through the
flashlight
just like in the cave that you saw
i can't believe i came all the way over
here and then realized it was dead end
got very annoyed
oh
gosh i just can't believe how annoyed i
got
ah okay
so it's definitely nothing up here i
just really was hoping you can't just
you can't do that you can't throw that
many enemies
at someone and not give them a reward of
at least
some ammunition
what is this
ah
it's all blocked off i can't go
oh well let's go home
oh no checkpoint reached
this sucks
wow
please give me ammo i literally have
hardly anything left
well coffee thank you i guess
the tree this ring was cut from started
growing in 1846
the year the oregon
oregon treaty was signed
other notable events marked on the rings
the washington territory was formed the
founding of the bright falls mining
corporation and the town itself
washington was granted statehood tree
damaged in a forest fire
the bright falls mining corporation
closes its doors after a volcanic
eruption below cauldron lake
mount 7 at mount saint helens erupts and
tree fell
by a storm
[Music]
we
ah
what are we go now and why i'm playing
son of ammo
really game
i can't believe it teased me with coffee
and no ammo
what wait it's actually just nowhere to
go
okay
that's
hmm
weird
ah game i don't trust you
am i being stupid
did i miss something
no
okay i guess we go back
that's weird
hmm
no there's no way i should be able to go
back
this far at least
something would have happened
to let me know that i was like on the
right tracks or whatever
nah what am i doing where am i going
is there a map or anything i don't think
there is
anyway can you guide me i can't do this
you're the writer what's the next part
of the story
where do we go
jump on the slog
because we got a checkpoint here
so it must have meant something
i don't want to shoot because i don't
have much ammo
so
yeah so the last thing we saw was this
weird bag and it was swinging
so it was being all eerie and weird
we got to get up there somehow
nothing that oddle
nothing to do with the swinging trunk no
map to show lovers peak so lover's peak
is under here i don't think we have a
map no
uh
[Music]
i'm pretty sure there's no map in this
game
nah
it's just reach lover's peak
uh
yeah
oh where's you
this is really weird
unless i do have to shoot those tree
trunks but
i don't really want to because i have
no ammo
and the game would just be really mean
if it's making me shoot these because i
need to get through here
i just need to get these trunks out of
the way i guess so i can go through the
you use the swing to launch yourself up
the mountain
i mean that would be
quite the feed
quite the feet austin
but i'm not quite sure that that's what
we're supposed to be doing here
should i
shoot it
what jesus
does
thank you for following
mo
moki attica
again sorry about that weird colors i
thought i updated them earlier it turns
out i've just messed everything up my
life
but i will try and fix it for next time
but thank you for following i appreciate
that um i am lost
that's i i don't know if you've been
here for a little while
but i am lost uh if anyone could help me
be
much appreciated i don't know if i
should go back i don't feel like i
should go back i feel like
that's
can i get up here somehow
i feel like going back would be very
counterproductive
but you know maybe
shoot it
shoot off the swing
ah i guess maybe
ask for it we've reached a checkpoint
anyway so if we die we're gonna start
again with
the 11 bullets that we have left so
if you want me to switch this sweet
sweet shoot the swing then we will shoot
this swing
nope
nothing
oh we don't have eleven we have oh yeah
we did have eleven
uh okay so that does nothing
so let's try shooting the logs
on the other side of the gate because
why not
nope that is nothing
also i don't need to apologize i am as
lost as you are i appreciate your
we're working this out together we'll
find this out together people
can i use this
to jump up on i don't think it's that
type of game really but um
no this is nothing i've got a nice
bullseye though
can he not climb over
oh my god ev you are a freaking genius
[Laughter]
thank you
i did not see that there
oh my gosh
okay we have eight bullets wish me luck
people
oh we'll let him get his breath back
okay
that was so strange though because you
it really seemed like that was a vital
clue piece but but no it was just a
little bit more a little last minute
laura we like it after the lore
oh please say this is basically the end
i have eight bullets this is not gonna
go well
let me go in
i love how he just leaped on there
i'm in
remain seated and do not swing
cabin [ __ ]
[Applause]
okay fine i didn't have to do anything
oh no i have eight ballots
are you kidding me
that flashlight's kid stuff excuse me
the flares will keep the bastards away
it's actually called
a clicker
is that where you caught it before
clicky click clicker
clicker that's type of zombie you can
see them too hell of course i see him
come on we gotta move why
because that's the way the story goes
yeah but let's move
i lost my gun back there
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
it took a moment but then i recognized
him he'd been on the ferry when i first
arrived here with alice
we were headed in the direction of
lovers peak there was no way this was a
coincidence he was the kidnapper come on
wake you better keep up
okay so we found the kidnapper
and he wants me to keep up but instead
i'm just walking around like an idiot
what a nice tree with little leaves on
it
i don't want to use a flair why is it
telling me to use flair i don't want to
use flat
where the hell is he gone
oh great we lost him
never going to catch up now not with
alan oh jesus christ help help sir where
did you go where'd it go sir
oh he's there okay
my hero
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
maybe i should have saved that flair
something happened i don't know take a
look at me thank you
use the flares from the emergency box to
hold them off while i get these boards
off yummy gun
yeah no can do
oh are you kidding give me the gun
thanks for following lilly brook
and
monkey attica i think i already said
that though
okay
just a little longer i almost got it
okay
oh [ __ ]
okay let's go oh god
[Music]
yeah i am
yeah i am
i feel good thank you
see the story was about him shooting one
of them as well remember i'll be honest
soon
about the kidnapper shooting the last
shadow whatever and then he was like
where's my wife
this is it wake the last stand there's
more players here get ready we fight
them as long as they keep coming okay
give me the goddamn gun they're coming
let's not have this go get with the
program wake
i am the program
ah
get out of here get out of here
i want a gun
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
god use another flag
hitting me
nice
okay i'm getting hand cramped jesus
there's more of them
oh [ __ ]
damn [ __ ] [ __ ]
big boy
why did you never go for the other dude
why is it always me
oh yeah because he has a gun and i don't
okay i can't even understand
oh i got hand cramps cut the act now
where's my wife i knew you were gonna
say that i read it all before you're a
hell of a writer he found my notes as
well you're gonna bring about something
glorious and terrible once we get you
some proper
editorial control
what the hell are you talking about
where's alice i want the entire
manuscript or she's gonna suffer bad
touch
oh
and they both die the end
has he got a gun now
yeah take his gun take his gun
okay
oh buddy
you'll be sorry
no come back here i swear i'll kill you
if you hurt alice do you hear me come
back here
there was another flower as well
oh he had alice that's true and he
wanted the manuscript because he thought
he had some magical power but i had no
manuscript to give him nice i had to get
back to barry and figure out my next
move
oh gosh
great so we're here on our own again
but at least we have a gun so that's
good
the kidnapper fired his gun one last
time
yeah that's the one that we just we just
lived out
on more than one occasion alice had
tried to explain to me how it felt to be
afraid of the dark
to her darkness wasn't simply the
absence of light but something more
tangible than that it was something you
could touch and feel
worse than that it was something with a
mind of its own something malicious and
malign
for her things changed when they were
wrapped in darkness they turned into
something else something foreign and
nothing was safe or innocent anymore i'd
never really understood what she meant
until now
um
maybe
this is all his understanding of like
her fear and because she's actually lost
he's just going crazy
with the thought of like
what
her mind could be going through right
now okay
the tree is alive
um
uh
anything back this way
no goodies no goodies
i see you
oh
well nice thing these traps are so
sparkly what can i do about it
can i press e on it no i think it's just
sparkly to tell me to stay away okay
i'll stay away
oh
okay can't go there
anything
for me to get
really
goodies can i
oh
can i get on this vlog please
it really looks like i can
whenever i try to it just doesn't let me
get in the slop
no
yeah no no
no
okay game
bye you keep your secrets
no
sorry i thought i saw a hidden message
i just want to find some more things
i hate being so
empty pocketed
fine
oh
so i can't i guess i can shoot them but
i
do i want to
warn me about these traps i wouldn't
want to get caught in one of them those
teeth look nasty
nasty
there's a lot of them here
world school
dizzy raw school
nasty
who says it like that
don't think it's dizzy rascal what's in
my side just saying that
i imagine someone like him though
okay i think i'm just making life harder
for myself because i actually just found
a way around having to do all of this
but i'm just
yay i was just what to say i just want
to do it because i'm scared that i've
missed something and lucky looking lucky
what they found here
sarah didn't care about the legal
threats wake's agent had made she let
wake go without argument because there
was something about him she couldn't
quite put her finger on something that
reminded her of her father
she didn't think wake would hurt his
wife
then she thought about the way he waded
into hartman that hair trigger rage
flaring up without warning
okay so she's suspicious
it wasn't us we didn't do anything
officer i swear
oh my gosh
he was waiting for us
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ]
okay
i think i'm going the wrong way anyways
where did i start from was it here
i think me going over to
the right let you just maybe
not have to worry about any of this
okay
well
we'll just keep on going this way
i just skipped it all didn't i
are you going down here
oh it's another tree
okay
me ah
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] bomb sucks
[Music]
okay
i think he's going insane
the man is going insane
uh
thank you for the
flares
open this box
looks important
oh geez what am i what are my computers
let's do this
where am i going
i'm looking for secrets
looking for stuff
there probably won't be anything
oh [ __ ] full sucks why did i do that
okay just go
you're too fast
too fast too fast
okay just go i i i can't be dealing with
this
that's a barrel is that a red vowel
oh i need to go up here okay let's go up
here
oh generator generator generator
that would be nice
oh officer dorito don't even get me
started on faster adam wake does not go
faster what do you
mean he hasn't got any cardio
he's a writer mate he sits at his desk
oh [ __ ] off
i got ammo
oh thank god
[Laughter]
so close
ah yes
ah
my arm hurts
it's it's a lot
because you're like spamming q spam and
e and then spamming your little finger
on shift
on and off because you need to
tap it at the same time as wasd
to try and do a dodge
so my fingers is just like this the
whole time
i don't know how these pro gamers do it
they must have some
really strong fingers
coffee yes very nice
let's have a cup of joe
oh
nice
okay let's read this new manuscript then
the night had been one desperate
situation after another i was exhausted
and my body felt as though it had been
chewed up and spat out the flashlight
was heavy in my hand and each pull of
the trigger sent a painful shock up my
arm but i was finally out of the woods
and things were looking up
that's when i heard the chainsaw oh no
oh no
that does not sound good
oh
i don't even have that much ammo left to
be honest
oh don't want to jump down there i think
i'll be here
be
one hurt boy
come on
i had heard the plane fall
it made no sense it was clear that it
had just fallen here but it was very old
and obviously hadn't flown in decades
looking at it shiver down
i love how i ran completely the wrong
way am i supposed to go towards that
what's like that
i've got one flare
where did this bloody plane go
oh here
oh yes arrow i will follow thee
oh i can
use my flashlight to get off the little
black bits
uh thanks for following zombie pool
i didn't mean to
press that button
up here okay
oh
hello
i can definitely hear a woman breathing
in my ear again
thank you for the flares you are very
kind is this when i hear the woman
breathing when i'm by these signs
because she's helping me i don't know
maybe i don't
when you hear a woman breathing you know
that life is good
i don't know
if that makes any sense it doesn't it
doesn't
okay
all right let's go trundling down here
then mr wake
[Music]
i don't want to
[ __ ]
oh no don't change your [ __ ] gun your
dick mod
i want to save the good one
[Music]
buttons
oh my god no [ __ ] off
am i out of
[ __ ] ammo
[Music]
[ __ ] me
ah
okay
i need to do this i'm sorry i don't know
why i'm saying sorry
nice
oh man
i didn't get on that
[Music]
all right officer narito enough for the
caps
i'm trying my best that's that's all i
can give you okay
okay this career
hello
oh this is stopped for some reason
yeah yeah yeah
oh [ __ ] off
[ __ ] [ __ ]
ugh
so difficult
okay
let's try that again
hunting your own food can save you money
i
mean they have a point
they have a point they're not being very
nice about it but they have a point
uh [ __ ] off i hate managed throw [ __ ]
the thing is you gotta light them up
until they do the poof that and then you
can shoot them
because if you don't do that it's just
gonna take forever to shoot them
oh [ __ ] off
oh god
nice
okay i'm out of batteries then that good
please give me some bad treats i'm gonna
need some matches i want some bad trees
well there's a kettle
but no i don't i don't want to get there
i'm waiting for one of them to say 15
minutes can save you 15 or more and your
car insurance
is that one of the youtube ads i haven't
seen that one i didn't think
ah
but you know what would be even nicer is
if i had some batteries
i mean i have two flares so it's not all
bad
but
yeah not feeling great about my
situation right now
i really hope we're coming to the end of
it because
yeah this isn't great
[ __ ] off
what the [ __ ] in hell
oh gosh
see this game this is what i mean about
the pacing sometimes it's like really
slow i'm just looking at things and
having fun enjoying life
and then it just seems to go whoop and
i'm like
hey
am i
thank you
that's nice any batteries
batteries
pick up what
oh manuscript
fine
i want battery the logging site was a
mess
the modular office had been pushed off
the cliff
deputy thornton climbed up from the
wreckage excited breathing hard from the
exertion
nobody there it's weird
don't you think that's weird
bored mulligan let out a mighty snort
hell it's always weird thornton just a
question of sorting out what kind of
weird it is this time around
yeah yeah
wow
i mean sorry i guess but i need to
survive uh so sorry for making a mess
i thought we saw something shiny down
there
sorry barrel
very rude of me
when barry saw the darkness attacked the
visitor center it made him a believer
the men al said he'd shot they hadn't
been just locals on crank
somehow the world had changed like the
channel had been switched without
warning you think you're watching a
sitcom and you're really watching a
horror show
when the birds started attacking the
cabin barry wasn't surprised just
terrified
ah so that's what barry saw the birds
the crazy birds
nice okay i mean
pantries though
but yeah the flares are good so that's
so good
hello
i'm just cleaning up the black gunk from
the floor one moment
who was that
any batteries
any batteries
no batteries very sad
yeah be sad
sad yag yaga sad
the darkness wears her face
as in alice
that that is a white rice
[ __ ] off
i literally
cannot even deal
eat that you piece of [ __ ]
yeah okay
[ __ ] off leave me alone
i have no time for you
i have no [ __ ] batteries man
okay good
still got some
these
still got two
so we're not doing too bad i just don't
want to use
all of my light sources
i wish this was
a thing to tell me the way
for me to find some special goodies
any special goodies oh look that's a
manuscript
picking up from this side
okay
shadow stirred and the wind picked up as
i ran through the forest i felt the dark
presence turning its gaze toward me then
the moonlight was blotted out by dark
shadows that raced violently across the
ground moving too swiftly to be natural
darkness gathered between the trees and
melt again to reveal the taken
no natural path had brought them here
i feel like we've already had that scene
quite a few times and probably quite a
few more i don't have any batteries
let's all say it
okay so i know which way to go i'm just
hoping for some batteries but i'm not
going to find them am i so should just
carry on
i'm doomed
doomed
oh my gosh
[Music]
is
nothing here really
nothing on the legs
[ __ ]
i think that was the point
[Music]
[ __ ] jesus i can't save [ __ ]
[Music]
there's two of the big ones [ __ ] me
okay change gun to your rifle to your
rifle to your rifle
come on oh he's so close
ah he just takes so long in between
shots
you cannot spam be aware
oh what back here again oh my god okay
wait is this the one where i have no
ammo or like what's happening here i
don't know
um
okay so
are you okay what's wrong with you
oh jesus
why why are you charged like this
dude
oh thank you
okay so i have three hunting rifle ammo
left
um i'm gonna pick up this one
i mean i'll read it oh okay good
i didn't technically need to do that
[Music]
okay so
oh no
uh
so my health does gradually just get
better over time so i'm just gonna stand
here for a little beat
oh wait no they didn't come up
it didn't happen until i went up so
maybe i'll just go this way
for now
oh it's still gonna happen it's still
basically the same way isn't it
okay
great
i use i use a
um
flashbang
thing
yes
[ __ ] jesus christ oh god i hate it
when they i'm out batteries again
oh
it's weird because it's like
not right in front of him it's where the
light is okay go go go
yeah
okay
i wish i could pick it back up and be
used
oh i can't believe i got [ __ ] zero
batteries again i'm back back that was
the beginning back to where i started
this sucks no
i'm fine
oh hello yes yes yes love you
oh yay thanks game
oh please say this is near the end of
the chapter i don't think i can take
much more i need to go back
where is he where's the little [ __ ]
i'll get him i'll get him i will
oh he'll get me we'll see
come on
get out of the way alan
oh [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] sucks jesus
god
jesus
so hard
okay
my neighbors will be like
who the [ __ ] is alan
ah my gosh
yeah baby
hey trey
vlogging is a hazardous occupation
[ __ ] you [ __ ] tits
got you
now just you me and you baby me and you
all the way baby
back
oh [ __ ] yeah
ah
iced it
that's so good
ah
[Laughter]
austin
who's alan oh why won't you go faster
oh geez what do my neighbors think of me
what the hell
wow
okay
oh
[ __ ] sake
oh
should i explore will i get rewarded for
it probably not will a big body come out
probably yes
nah nothing's gonna happen is it
i just need to look out for those hidden
messages with my flashlight
but i think we're near the end now
anyway because that was the end of his
story page remember it was the chainsaw
dude and then he went towards the thing
of light
which i'm guessing is up here
hello
i'll be there soon just make sure you
keep the lights on
thank you for the well done death
i appreciate it uh we do actually have
some bespoke uh emotes coming soon
so look out for them um getting them
commissioned right now so it should be
very exciting all right birds
go away barry's scared of you
i still had to reach barry at the cabin
but at least i was out of the woods
oh come on there can't be much left
really
i mean at least i've got some batteries
but
[Applause]
oh damn is that what the cabin is that's
a lot of birds
uh i'd have to get the car from the lock
garage it would get me back to bury
faster and the headlights were a welcome
bonus
so
yeah if the freaking battery isn't dead
because someone's just left the lights
on
where would the keys be
oh the fbi agent's command froze me in
place i considered surrender it was all
falling apart anyway
i could give in let someone else deal
with it but it felt all wrong
called instinct his posture the way he
held the gun he was no friend
shots ringing in my ears i leaped for
the hole in the fence and stumbled into
the darkness beyond
oh no
okay so if someone comes trying to be a
cop
doper leads him
hello
hello
uh someone's in here i had to find the
key to the garage i know i know that
someone's in here you're not alone i
don't
think we can hear lots of weird things
i needed the garage key to get to the
car
yeah but where's the garage key
hello
i need to be okay
why was that one locked
i don't like you me no leggy
oh hello a story is not a machine that
does what you tell it a story is a beast
with a life of its own you can create it
shape it but as the story grows it
starts wanting things of its own change
one thing and you set off a chain
reaction of events that spreads through
the whole thing the characters have to
be true to themselves the events need to
follow a logic that fits the story a
single flaw and the magic is gone the
story dies
alice dies
yep
i [ __ ] knew it [ __ ] knew it
[ __ ] knew it [ __ ] do it
i'm glad we checked that dog because you
know how that would have been scared or
something
no one can stop me now i'm in a car i'm
gonna
which way do i go
this way okay
oh [ __ ]
it's hard to drive off-road
can i get out
how do i get out
oh
i don't already know how to get out of
here
i don't think i can get out
come on come back
i think it's just one more on it
oh no definitely
donuts
okay
can i really not get out to go in there
because that's not fair you can't tell
me about a place and then not let me go
in there
please
no it's not gonna let me out
okay
i'm putting this car through
quite some stuff
oh
barry
very boo bear i'm coming for you
very windy roads though
oh scheiser
i'm coming
where now oh it's up
there i mean
now what
what
something i can do
surely gotta get out
i am not
part of me wants to go all the way back
just to go
get that extra box but you know what i
really can't bother because it's so far
away how do i get over here
wait is that
a siren
a siren that i should be wary of i think
the flare gun was probably the best
weapon i could imagine against the dark
things i was facing
ah thank you
love you
hello
it was the kidnapper you son of a [ __ ]
where's my wife
wait wait you deliver the manuscript and
you can have your woman back simple as
that
listen
listen
i'm gonna need time to finish it i still
need to write the ending i need
a week
it's not done
i need a week
two days
the old bright falls coal mine is nearby
you can find it easy city boy the main
building there at noon
you bring the manuscript you get your
wife if not well
get me yes yes i get you
okay
so that's why he's going crazy in his
room just writing and writing writing
and look at all these birds
barry had talked about birds over the
phone
the darkness controls the taken
where did all these come from i'm very
happy for them though
okay i'm guessing i gotta shoot one of
these in the
i sky so glad you're here a couple of
them got in here before i blocked the
chimney this isn't normal these birds
are weird
how do i get in
uh oh this is gonna be a big one
oh
i'm trying
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
oh [ __ ]
ah
where's the flock they're right above me
jesus christ is so loud
[Applause]
so loud
they're gone
even though they weren't going when he
said it but i'm
i'm oh sorry sorry you were having a
psychotic episode man
yeah
i sent barry to the town to ask around
about a man fitting the kidnapper's
description
he'd go through the archives of local
paper perhaps he could learn something
anything about the island in the cabin
that it disappeared
the man wanted a manuscript
i had to try to write him one to get
alice back
for me the supernatural had always been
nothing but a metaphor for the human
psyche a tool to use in writing fiction
now it was happening for real and i
couldn't put a single word on paper
hmm
barry wheeler speaking this is rose rose
she's pages okay
we'll be there in less than an hour
soon
have a great day
yeah hope you come back soon
welcome to the oh dear
so that lady is the one that gave us the
keys to the non-existent house where
our wife actually went missing
she's controlling
[Music]
situations
for some reason and somehow
hey xfx
end of episode two
we did it i'm quite proud i'm quite
proud of that one to be honest i did
struggle
but thank you so much for all of your
wonderful words of encouragement i
really appreciate it it keeps me sane
previously on alan wake alice has been
kidnapped
please help me oh no no go back go back
come back
okay so
yes please i would like to quit
thank you so much for watching it's been
great
i like your dancing thank you very much
as always you can catch me streaming out
every thursday at 8 30 pm
g
m t
i always have to catch myself it's like
bst no that's in the summer it's not
summer anymore it's
gmt now
so i'll see you
back here
next week for episode three of alan mike
um
yeah but that was oh that was a that was
a crazy one i love how it started and it
was so chill it's probably gonna say
next episode to be honest it's probably
gonna be really chill at the beginning
and then all of a sudden it will just
ramp up and i'll be screaming and my
hand will be hurting and i'll just be
like
but no i'm really enjoying it
i really do like the premise that alan
wake is a writer and hence why like
junkie controls and him you know not
being able to sprint very far or like
shoot in quick succession makes sense
because he's not a fighter he's not you
know he's not soldier he hasn't been
trained for any of this
um so
yeah it makes sense why it wouldn't be
as smooth as like other games where
you're playing you know
resident evil for instance where you're
playing someone who has been trained to
take care of zombies and stuff
in like a military fashion
um but yeah it's
it's very interesting and very enjoyable
and i really like reading the pages and
just being like oh so this this is gonna
happen in the future and then when it
does happen you're like i know what's
gonna happen now because i read the
pages
um
yeah very good very good do finger
push-ups okay i i will try i will try
uh i haven't played control but i have
watched control so i probably won't play
it to be honest it looked interesting uh
i think it probably would have been
better to play than to watch uh
but yeah i mean it looked good it looked
interesting i don't know i don't think i
got the right sense of it because i was
watching it i felt like the gameplay
loops were quite
like similar it was just trying to
find someone and then going back to the
same location and then trying to find
someone again
uh i think alan wake is definitely more
my kind of my kind of jam
uh
but yeah i'm gonna say goodbye to who i
can see in the chat so goodbye to xfx
i'm sorry you missed but if you want to
follow or subscribe or whatever you want
to do
then hopefully you'll catch your catch
next thursday's stream
um oh i should also put the discord
there you can also keep up with
everything that i do
on discord as well so i'll just get an
invite for that and then
anybody who wants to be can be in that
is good
join the
discord hello amar i'm so sorry but
we're going now but if you want to catch
me next week make sure you're
subscribed follow me on twitch all that
good stuff and you can follow join the
discord if you want to and then you'll
know when i'm streaming next when i will
be streaming next is just next thursday
8 30 p.m as per usual
um
but yeah so goodbye to death 157 goodbye
ip196 goodbye sedinator goodbye gaming
with malachi
goodbye
emma oh they just came goodbye thomas
please don't waste your ammo on enemies
who are covered in darkness
no i i try to um
uh like you know get rid of their light
first
but i didn't have any
batteries for most of that playthrough
so uh i'm sorry i'm not gonna waste my
time trying to do it with my normal
light when i can't like blast them
because it takes a bloody long time uh
but it worked it worked i actually had
quite a lot of hammer at the end there
uh
by zed
and i think that's everyone goodbye to
anyone who i haven't seen in the chat
and
[Music]
uh oh kevin deakin came i don't know if
you're still here but goodbye kevin i'm
sorry people people came as i was
leaving
but yeah goodbye
to everyone in the chat and goodbye
also uh to anyone who is just watching
as always i really appreciate you being
here as well so have a lovely day
everything see you next thursday
uh new video on the way as well
is studio tour so that should be cool
okay i'm gonna leave now